hey
hello everyone welcome to gamespot's
second stream charity stream of the day
we are raising money for ablegamers
um a fantastic charity that makes gaming
accessible for many many people from
different backgrounds
and uh disabilities i am joined today by
lucy james
super eye patch wolf hello everyone i
would like to apologize
for immediately ruining the stream and h
bomber guy
hello i would also like to apologize for
not stopping him
what you may be wondering what are super
ipad wolf and age bomber guy talking
about
why is lucy's face buried in her palms
and more importantly where is the video
game
on the stream well ladies and gentlemen
let us spin you a tale
it involves us saying what game should
we play and everyone's saying
how about heave hoe it's a fun game
that's that's not quite accurate i was
like
i believe i believe the way i put it was
timur
lucy h-bomb why don't you guys just step
back a minute i've got this one
we should play the fantastic multiplayer
game heave-ho
a guaranteed good time yep guaranteed
good time and we all went that sounds
great so we all bought heave-ho
and then we all played heave-ho to start
to get comfortable with it
in anticipation of the stream and then
we all tweeted
we're gonna play heave hole the gamespot
graphics team
got together to make loads of graphics
that said they see
h bomb and super patch iphone wolf will
be playing heave-ho
and wouldn't you know it there is no
online multiplayer in evo
well i mean i googled can you play repo
online
and the official heepo account did tweet
you can play heave-ho online however
clicking through to the tweet they
they actually said you can play evo
online with parsec which is to say that
you can't
so that's great um
so instead what we have done is we have
decided to explain this story
in detail as we stall for time
while everyone downloads gang beasts
um i would just i would like to thank
gamespot for what is
undoubtedly going to be my final
appearance on the site
now this is the kind of this is the kind
of chaos we live for
this is the kind of chaos that we we we
like encourage
this will this will be a twitch clip in
a in in about
an hour's time that one person will
watch and that one person will be me
laughing at it but uh
but in the meantime what i can say is my
copy of gang beast has downloaded
so it's mine i'm ready to go you know
um so i'm going to start
just adjust brightness on my on my
lightsaber real quick
okay there okay all right okay i think
that covers up the imperfection
it actually really hurts this
okay i have a real um issue where
the light uh makes me yawn like if you
ever looked into a light and it just
sort of made you yawn like makes you
sneeze
oh yeah and i get that all the time now
and it's really bad considering
what my job is that's
awesome i i wear contact lenses so i've
always been able to like cut onions
the dream i can't do that i don't know
if that helps with that
i just don't look up at the sun too much
i never go outside
can you breathe
another game that begins at the loudest
volume known to humanity oh my god i'm
dying
[Music]
please god turn down okay oh god i can
hear you all now
okay i i can also hear you all all right
now let's
play i'm just gonna switch this game
from heave-ho
to gang beasts
what on oh on the uh on the old overlay
there we go
i was gonna say i'm not sure i think
it's too late to uh
change it on the title ask you can do it
on twitch
i don't have the facilities for that big
man don't think you got the facilities
for that big man
all right i'm already loving this game
because it says online as an
option like second yeah second
um what time do you have to send invites
yes which i will do
right now i also like that it's the mass
effect one
okay how do i
how do i can you can you guys just join
on me from the um
uh steam thing from steam yeah
because i'm in a lobby but
um
oh wait is it oh wait i got it here oh
i pressed a bunch of buttons and it gave
me a
been invited invite invite screen you
truly love to see it here we go there we
go
is loud but i'm not sure if it still is
the game is loud
but then i'm assuming i can turn it down
a bit
uh who are we missing um i think i
accepted the invite and then
did something let me uh yeah i accepted
it and it just booted up the game it
didn't actually
okay okay oh we just launched
the game there we go
sweet okay i'm in
submit wait what is the mode waves
football
melee wait how am i not in
i'm in my own lobby yeah two eye patches
there's two eyepatch wolves what
okay uh oh one's gone one's gone
okay that i guess that's good
uh oh here we go
join game join game yes
there we go got it okay i made it okay
all right we're doing 2v2
and we're gonna go to oh no why is there
two of me
okay
let's go we're in business here we did
it we're in a video game
we did it four online internet
personalities managed to
form a video game
[Laughter]
everyone knows that video game
journalists aren't real gamers okay
yeah okay um
i have not played this very well how do
you how do you i can't even remember how
to play this game
how do you move
are you stuck i don't even know if i'm
oh
i'm in i'm i'm in something
i'm being attacked by firefighters
oh no is this one of those games that
really slows down
oh here we go oh yeah it does just
the controls just are kind of mushy yeah
they are very mushy
what's the grab button again is it right
bumper oh yeah it's the top it's the
bumpers
who's this staying still yeah is this
you lucy
what apparently nothing oh you're
supposed to be you're supposed to be on
the same
car this you just stood there the entire
time
but i i'm using my
xbox control it and it's it
it's doing nothing try pressing i have
to use my keyboard
try pressing the keyboard see if that
works oh
yeah i can i can i can wash uh
what's the buttons uh right bumper good
luck with that
oh my god wait get away from me
yeah come here no
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god yes
you installed fortnite oh wait this is
over
yeah now says h4 guy's volume is
slightly lower than everyone else
oh i can turn myself up yeah it might it
might be a thing in discord that you can
do
does anyone know what they grabbed i
just flicked my preamp up so
hopefully that helps oh yeah that's good
uh normally
try controller
right of m the um the arrow oh the
arrows guys
no
that was me i actually gotta win this
one because i cannot get back up i'm
just holding
holding on for dear life over there you
hold on to things this is the right
bumper yeah right bumper and left bumper
okay oh my god you're just getting
bullied over there
i can't even help you i can't even help
you oh yes
yes no no yeah
okay how do you get people's names to
show up
because i only get them when they're
dead yeah
same for me i've just identified uh who
the cat is
i know the cat is my teammate and the
two firemen i need to
throw away i'm so sorry i'm picking me
up
so sorry oh shows
[Laughter]
mom said it's my turn to play the xbox
and you get that onesie now that is a
great onesie to be fair huh
it's just me and you why are we fighting
where are your teammates
right i know the buttons this time so
okay
wait do we have to fight each other now
oops i'm so sorry
i think so my ping occasionally really
blasts up so if i
get murdered it's not my fault oh no
they're there
why is it this this map is not good
[Laughter]
no
draw i thought i had you there
all right let's go
i don't like the laughing wow lucy okay
i thought i was
on the right i'm so sorry but if you win
this think like you've got this
already no yes
jump on him you stamp on him
how do you climb back up
get off
oh my goodness it doesn't help that like
we're both
guys yeah and so i just i keep thinking
that i'm eyepatch wolf
yeah we should we should we should mix
up skins yeah
because that happens me as well no wow
he paid me oh oh okay
oh okay okay
it's gotta be a way to climb back up
well i mean
[Applause]
i'm very slowly i'm very slowly climbing
down
somehow oh red wings
red winds finally
it's true oh no this is where the big
comeback comes
yeah see now that i know what the
buttons are i'm in
i don't like the weird oh wow let's
okay okay let's go yeah
what he's gonna do what he's gonna do
you see this you see this this is what's
gonna happen
yeah come on just try it just try it
what's this simpsons oh no no no no
no
what's that simpson's line right here
look at me just waving my hands and if
you walk in that's your fault
i'm gonna i'm gonna let you deal with
this yeah yeah
victory
oh god oh
okay i don't like this laughing once of
lockdown i'm enjoying a game that seems
to be about just holding people
uh my phone made a memory for me the
other day google photos made this memory
where it said uh lucy memory for you
hugs oh oh
no oh no oh no okay
i will avenge you brother please damn
yeah no oh my god what are you doing
down there
let go oh god oh no
stop it come on stop it go on horace
that was some smash brothers ledge
grabbing text
oh man do we win yeah
you did all right trainers train is not
the best map
lucy while i'm messing with the uh with
the settings can you
check the bring up the uh donations
i can and i will um i've just become a
chicken
uh thank you for everyone donating we
are done uh raising money for ablegamers
an incredible charity
who do amazing work um they
help they do so many things they help
combat social isolation
uh for people who want to play video who
play video games or have disabilities
they also work as accessibility
consultants and they also work
on creating specialized hardware for
people
with disabilities to play and their
overall mission is so that everyone can
game
and we are raising money for them
because i think if the last year has
shown
anything it's that like everyone is
stronger together when you play games
and gaming is such a great way
to chat to people and maintain
friendships and so everyone should game
that was a very long
way of explaining that they did great
work uh so tinyurl.com
playforall2021 if you are able to donate
if you're not able to donate that's fine
please just uh share the stream and
maybe
someone that you share to we'll donate
that would be fantastic so
since um since you played uh
metal gear solid this morning we've had
darius with 50
thank you very much darius uh anonymous
with a hundred bucks
and another anonymous with twenties
thank you oh thank you
nice all right wow
this looks more manageable um i've
picked this up we all
helps replicate my iq in the game so i
think that'll give me an edge
wait which one are you are you
the rick and morty get off no
no let me go no let me go
just get eaten by octopus there's
clearly a gap in between our hands what
the hell is this all about
are you still alive down there yes what
the hell
hi tam get it chicken leave me alone
chicken
oh in the water you go oh it's got me
oh yes yes you get fed to the kraken
and you get fed to the kraken get in the
water
yes let me out no no
this is taking a turn yeah
oh my god i'm punching it my punches do
nothing
oh my god how are you back that's insane
who's got a oh i thought that was you
walking over giant bench
i'm just gonna take this over here
what is the punch button
it's just the grab buttons oh god
an offering for the gods
no not me no i'm
yeah oh what oh we
we're not in teams it doesn't look like
it this is everything every match every
weird jelly bean human for themselves
well this changes everything
i remember this i remember this level
i'm not a fan of the floor
it's looking i feel like it's gonna
betray yeah get away from me
oh whoa oh whoa what's that what what is
that all about
sausages
i'm just going to casually uh skirt
around this corner
[Music]
how do you stay away from me stay away
from me you don't want none of this
smoke
oh wait no i'm on i'm on
no no yes
stop pumping that wall and fight me
yes victory is mine
oh god no
all right how do you climb hey stay away
from me
stay away from me no oh
yes how many times i've seen
this listen i feel like i'm determined
if i'm going down you're coming with me
don't you go
no no yes
no
[Music]
no
how did she survive that that's
ridiculous
i don't like this i don't know this
wreck guy
yes get it
is the punch just the grip buttons but
you mash it oh it is yeah you just press
it
it happens oh did you knock me out
apparently
yeah you can do that yeah god well
i could hit with these poles you're
gonna have to come get me
wait what what happens here if you just
keep
running away long enough streamers start
to leave
viewers start to leave that's what
happens
[Music]
oh you're back if you could get oh the
catapult
the catapult
i always wonder like soup factories if
there's like a big fat that you could
like climb into
would it be warm did they warm it at the
factory
i really don't like it we're like a long
straw
you get a big ladle i think a lot about
snoop factories
it's my main dream and most of my
nightmares to work in one or to own one
um to be trapped in one while a
terminator slowly rises from the soup
just just ministroni on his fingers
[Music]
oh god what was that move yeah i was
looking up the controls there there's
actually a few different
moves no no
john's got an advantage she's been
looking at moves
down so much for my moves i have chosen
violence
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna keep
punching you uh the main one if you're
on keyboard is just a lift move
shift oh no oh
what the hell
okay uh the chat's asked how it's asked
ask john how to do a roman cancel
oh man a quick quick guilty gage hook
there for everyone
you know good job
a common cultural touchstone guilty gear
get off
um how dare you get back on there
stop it thus uh you'll discover that
whenever i play
online games and things aren't going my
way i will just say stop it
in hopes that i will eventually it's a
legitimate tactic
uh an insight into my psyche is that for
the younger years of my life i was the
younger sibling
uh and then my sister was too old so
like i would rarely rarely see her so
then i became de facto
sibling so i get the best of both worlds
when it comes to playing online games
on aboard the chunder wheel oh
just grabbed me by my tail did
a theme park in the uk called gulliver's
land
no no no i had a friend who worked there
who claimed someone got beheaded there
what what
like they they stuck their head out
of like one of the slow ones like while
it went into a tunnel oh my god
i haven't this is not coming if it's not
true i have heard that same urban
legends
yeah about gulliver's land specifically
yeah
so there's gull of his land and then
this call of this world
oh no so which how do they open a world
after the
catastrophic land incident there are six
different gullivers uh it says
gulliver's world resort land resort
kingdom resort valley resort
dinosaur and farm park oh my god four
short breaks
i feel sick why are you so resilient get
off
because naruto taught me to never give
up and protect your way of the ninja
yeah you just do pull-ups over there
good luck getting back up here
and i have to deal with rick sanchez
well first you'll have to master oh my
god the the
thing the car the wheel is slowly
collapsing
if i can quickly grab you and throw you
off i won't have to get on the car
no regular
shift or yeah i'm playing on keyboard oh
no
yes i'm also looking up the controls
what in the world what in the world is
going on
what is happening
oh my god
oh wow oh no
you just like came are you it's getting
absolutely worked over there
no my body
no we've mentioned the terminator a lot
already but like i just looked away
because i was looking up the keyboard
controls and then i saw you appear from
under the floor and then just grab on
my hubris
[Laughter]
i am just standing safely right out the
fighting on the wheel i'm just standing
here watching this and this
you've been on a journey my friend all
right let's do this
i'm swimming oh you're still alive rick
what is
happening what are you doing down there
i don't know
[Music]
there's a kick button well done
there's a kick button
um okay okay apparently there was a kid
who got decapitated on a water slide
at gulliver land oh
that's not how you want to go out it's
very has changed enough that i assume
that they're all made up yeah
it's not coherent enough uh
oh okay well i tried to kick and i fell
off if you had if you had to go out
by way of amusement park right which
ride would you pick
i always loved in rollercoaster sims
building one that would fling people off
yeah yeah
yeah i'd like i'd like to ride a death
coaster
for me as you know you know you get
those swings that once they pick up
enough speed you're basically just like
a lateral
yeah yeah if like one of those like went
really fast and just detached and it
just like yielded me across the country
if that was my way to go i wouldn't mind
i'd be all right with that
yeah i'd probably go with the haunted
house because then i could be a ghost
oh that's pretty good that's a network
right
yeah you'd be traveling you could
oh my god people are learning how to
fling
disgusting i can get them up there but i
don't know how to throw properly no
um oh it's the y button the button i've
been using to celebrate is actually a
button for attacking wow did you see
that my head like
teleported across the map i've got two
of them we're all going off
no
i'm taking everyone with me um we had
some donations i'll read them out just
while we're between rounds uh
where are we at uh anon gave 20 and then
luke
gave 20 with uh with the message gamers
rights
um but g-a-y m-e-r um
thank you uh anonymous gave 20. uh
frederick knudsen
uh gave 150 dollars i think he's sweet
right frederick
wow thank you wait that's frederick
didn't we yeah i know that guy yeah
guys that's down the rabbit hole yeah oh
amazing
thank you so much wow um sasquatch gave
twenty dollars and thirty four cents uh
thank you so much
simon uh gave 20 bucks
um and then jay radcliffe gave ten
dollars and said look at this nerd
looking up the controls
hey bro hey in this brutal life
you go for whatever advantage you can
get you're right there
harris it's either
just having a [ __ ] the control what's
happening down there look up the
controls are be
controlled oh my god
you're actually scaling the wall
i need to get the hell out of there
oh my god what the [ __ ] you're in for a
while
holy [ __ ] you just like cleaned me out
with a punch
and harris is playing street fire now
ah this is how we do it i love it
they've got security cameras
and they follow you as well yeah oh it's
on
ah luke in the chat says only nerds look
up controls real gamers just mash random
keys
what's up talk your [ __ ] life
yes oh i was so proud of when i wrote
that line that i went into the other
room and told my partner about it
it's such a good life it's very good you
voice it so well
it's the best thing yes
no of course what we're talking about
for people who may not know is the uh
uh super apache wolf's uh space jam
video right
it's a documentary space documentary my
apologies
which you can find on youtube now um
it's
excellent and it's also like a weird
fever dream
i think that was a fun video to make
there a small number of my following
really hated it
but i was happy to see how much how many
people seemed to into it
listen i i watched that um i had taken
an edible and i watched that and let me
tell you
that that is the perfect experience oh
boy it was an experience
so once you get them up in the air is
there a way to actually launch them or
are you kind of just trying to place
them i just like
let them go oh my god
in order did you just clothesline me the
sign collapsed when i tried to grab it
i just got off clothesline
i'm back baby
oh wait so how did you
how did you grab i wonder how you did
that clothesline that was
ridiculous sold out like one
cleaned me out oh god oh god
this is easy easy
you do this and then you do this and
then we and then we both
die well i feel like it's the end of toy
story
he's i always wanted to upload a
pirate torrent of toy story but where it
fades out
towards the end when they're all it
looks like they're all going to die
i think that's a better movie yeah
at least put it on kazaar or something
like that
yeah i hung on for dear life the entire
time
oh my god that's so good okay great
this is a poor showing from me i really
need to up my game here
oh this is this is bad this will be
chaos
oh my god leave me alone
fights in tight faces
no no i was trying to get the other
no yes i'm back in no i'm not i'm out
again
get me back in yes get off
get out yes
lego me you're clearly not holding my
hand
you're clearly not holding my hand let
go of me he's back
yes sorry lucy
i was like i'm just gonna stay here
knowing all the time
oh john you have to put your camera back
on oh
[ __ ] what happened there oh no so now
the nightmare scenario has happened oh
no
oh it's more nightmare it's fine it's
fine
for a little period of time you'll just
get two of me okay
oh no sorry rick oh no this is let me
let me put you down let's finish this
game
and then i'll fix this okay uh you guys
carry on for a second i will
figure this out oh my god respect i will
not
oh no i'm going for the free win i'm
taking both of these lads off get off
oh my god i just picked up two people
and threw him off and then
went to my own doom
oh boxing ring
where is out in this is it the ground i
think it might be out of the ring yeah
just anywhere around the ring
yeah oh yeah wow
camera should be back now
not yet yeah
no wow oh my god
oh
how did you do jumping dive um
i think it was uh jump and then control
like space bar and then control
hmm i believe tamora
set us up yeah i i deliberately
deactivated john's camera so everyone
will be distracted
so they're like i didn't want to say it
yeah i'm motivated you know
he knew he knew he didn't have online i
must
i could get a play the long con
does he wanna
[Laughter]
this is why he's been in invisible mode
he's been practicing practicing
i've got a new tactic and that is to
hide
because i cannot beat any of you in a
straight fight
oh no oh god
this is already bad
down i go instantly destroyed
okay i'm just gonna wander over here and
oh
oh my god i came to help you and you
this is some straight up titanic
[ __ ]
goodbye forever
[Laughter]
unbelievable
oh
this is the best oh this is pretty good
there's there's the um there was one at
the xbox conference the other day
which is just like you animals get
off oh get off
this is a new dance everyone
uh it'll be in fortnight soon you're
doing a flip
that was a i've seen ray mysterio do
that move how are you doing this
oh my goodness what is going on here
no one ever expects a hole in the ground
okay incredible scenes
wow we're at one thousand three hundred
and sixty two dollars already
sweet thank you wow thank you so much
everyone awesome
great work um
no and all we had to do was stream very
badly
let go my hair lucy you know how much
that hurts let go
what yes
no tap
wait what no um
yeah yeah there's a fan there's a fan
i'm just i'm just gonna do sick moves
oh no it's not fair just came back with
me now okay
it's not back for me yet oh it should be
live in the car
but this chord comes if you right click
on it it might refresh it
okay i had to do that and they just came
back okay yeah you're back for me
let me let me let's just finish this
game and then i'll i'll i'll mess with
that
because i don't want you stealing my
victory away from me any of you
i don't even know if i'm in the lead
i think you are oh good thank you i
think that might be some false modesty
there yeah yeah yeah yeah we need to do
this
does it if you have loads of stars does
that mean you're winning
so we're all going to get time right now
[ __ ] try it
get off oh [ __ ] huh come here rick
get out of here and now you as well oh
he's already defeated
you can get up
um
so we're all off to town this time right
now yeah oh my god i think i don't think
we can take him
i think the odds are even if we team up
yeah
i feel bad that we teamed up on him and
got a draw
i call a truce a truce i tell you
get back here no no
let me live let me live i will take all
of you out
help me
hr someone get hr i'm being bullied have
an email waiting for me
to get in there no never let go
okay right get him in just
if you can't be the king you can be the
king maker
okay this is unbelievable
all right back where it all began
do we have to be over here i've learned
the secret yeah
get away from me get away from me you
get away from
me what's going on
don't look at me oh no
no
oh no
should have gone with you i saw you guys
like you play right there
i don't like the way this icon's moving
cumulatively we have more stars than
timur but timur will win
if he you know just because he gets
first past the post it's ridiculous
let go of me lucy no let go of me for
the greater good for the greater good
i will punch you you're gonna have to
like jump on it see if it can loosen it
i'm sure to shove it oh no no
yes yes so you get for bullying
that's what happens when you bully me
no one gets the point matt hawking thank
you for the ten dollars
good to see you all again looking
forward to the streams of donating to a
great cause
matt was matt was great with um i
remember he watched
i was fixing the stream and you punched
me
that was the most brutal punch i've ever
seen
it's more there's no way to tell what
happened we just accepted that you're
out of the game
i'm pretty sure twitch archives every
moment you're alive
i don't know if that's true but we
shouldn't check either way
no it's it goes against the referee's
um autonomy to to re-litigate you have
to
undermine the officials you undermine
the game
oh i like this one do you
how do you like getting thrown out come
here
no leave me alone i'm just a sleeping
chicken
oh no all my royal rumble royal rumble
wow what was happening there tom you're
like swinging me around okay
stop it no i'm sorry i fell down
it's all on you the host definitely has
advantage in this game
i can't believe it sorry i just got word
there for anyone watching on my twitch
channel the wrong donate link is coming
up because it's nightbotted to my other
charity stream
so you can just donate off like the main
gamespot charity stream which you can
find if you just check the
the twitter it's tenural.com forward
slash play for all 2021
get out of there rick
what is morty short for is it mortimer
yeah probably
a horrible name it's very adam's family
in it
tomorrow it doesn't need to be like this
also tam
i've got to commend your um holding back
there because i reckon tomorrow you're
gonna go
yeah there you go yeah yeah
just try and hit me one of you's gonna
what are you doing over here i see you
no
leave me alone
let me out
he's trying not to perpetuate the cycle
of getting
i want peace i want peace in our land
ah you asked for this i never noticed
you
i've brought a great evil down with me
where are you i know you're hiding lucy
is still hiding in the corner
lucy i am nowhere
don't worry about it you're over here
somewhere is there another side here
what's that oh no wait
where are you oh my god i'm stuck
i saw you go there and i was like i'm
gonna i'm gonna allow this i'm gonna
allow this
what is god oh my god
hiding in the shadows the real villain
it was you all along
you never see a milford man never see me
get away fully looks like a chicken shop
mascot has lost the plot
um
yes
i've only just arrived but everything is
on fire so i assume things are going
well
that's great it's going well yeah it's
going perfectly it's great as good as we
can so glad we always intended to play
gang beats yes
i know yeah i went to bed last night
being like can't wait for some gang
beasts
gang beast is one i haven't played in a
while i'm really excited to play it
again
well well well look what happened here
well well well what happened
oh a socialist audiophile thank you for
the twenty dollars
that was a great username and audio file
thank you social audiophile
thank you conrad thank you for the audio
file and the socialism
yes i'm slowly remembering how to climb
oh here we go how do i grab i'm just
punching
i think maybe this is what i'm going
wrong um it's the punch buttons together
and then you hit shift to actually pick
them up
yeah so then yeah i can break notes up
here though look at this
just moves
there's so much freedom in control and
and so little at the same time
yeah it's incredible i mean i want to
see what like high-level gang beasts
looks like
yeah you're watching it it's it's
playing out in front of your very eyes
[Laughter]
just rick sanchez and this weird blue
yes yes yes
what you don't realize is i live
underneath here
and i i will return oh god oh oh
no i'm just i'm just hanging out what
are you doing hey hey hey hey
hey you don't want this beef trust me
okay no i don't i don't i don't but at
the same time
i told you no
let go of me yes i live
[Laughter]
that's what happened in the lives again
oh
oh oh we got it
i don't like that it's for me next yeah
yeah
all right he's climbing immediately
oh no ah
i got launched off the side
gravity was my ultimate enemy
you win again gravity what you gonna do
now oh my god that's
that is brutal oh no no no
how do i how do i climb
i'm a coward how did you even get up
there
i'm not really sure really just kind of
straddling that thing over there
i don't like that you're making weird
laughing noises as you do it like oh
[ __ ]
don't wiggle too much that's my pro tip
to you that's the secret
okay
oh wow oh
i genuinely thought tam would have won
because i thought i don't know what's
going on i've i've got like so many
stars right now
it's first to like 700 no
he's easy get back here come on don't do
it
you've got too much get out
[Music]
against me
so resilient just get off
oh my god did you do a jump kick at me i
did
okay okay i'm genuinely tired from that
paris i was exhausted i was so sure you
were gone
come on
i don't know how i got up here
oh this is brutal i'm trying to
kick you off guys tamora's still alive
we have to think about this
that's a good point okay right true
truth
[Music]
that's
powerful no yes
best we can hope for best we can before
it's voltron but instead of victory it's
mutually a short destruction
i can't believe i'm being ganged up on
like this that's interesting
oh my god you're the beast and we
are the game
what are you doing up there
no no
all right so it's a fifth fight you're
after is it
oh
please someone help me i'm stuck okay
i'll come get you if i don't get
destroyed
i'm coming wait wait wait give me your
hand
oh my god
oh yes oh no
there you go are you just going to throw
them both in
no help okay
oh my god these flipping people
open let me live
oh i thought you were up oh no wait uh
there you go okay i'm trusting you
help oh no no
oh okay it's okay he's down
oh no oh wait oh god yes
and i saved you as well now what we have
to fight
we have to fight it's it's tragic but it
must be the way
once we can oh this yet okay okay
get it yeah okay i'm out
that was amazing come on
get down there look at that she saved
you and now you're pummeling her
oh and then you knocked me out oh wait
i'm still alive
what
i do want to see what high level play of
this looks like now right i mean
probably
not exactly apart from this question
it's off i want to know the tricks
you just trip over sam you
you you panned out with me in real life
yeah you know the answer is yeah very
easily goes from standing to fallen over
without any movement
nope no
yes no you can just eat it
yes that's probably the worst way to die
yeah into one of those machines meat
grinder i can destroy anything
oh wait so we've gone from how would you
rather die
at a theme park how would you rather die
in general in general well one thing
about the grinder is one of your last
thoughts would be like oh i'm gonna look
real [ __ ] when this is all done
i'm
okay i'll climb this up i'll climb this
up don't let go okay i won't let go
uh i love titanic uh
there we go what happened there
i was hanging on and it just just
dropped me
yes we made it
oh no yeah
how did i win that i have no idea i lost
one to four i was definitely dead
no although
i feel like we have really leveled the
playing field a bit more and all it took
was for three of us to gang up on
one of us yeah it's terrible that's why
we're all pro gamers
yeah oh my god oh god i was really
hoping that
the stream would get me scouted for the
pro gang beasts team um
what are you doing down there tomorrow
it spawned me on one of the cracks
i like moved to the left a bit and i was
dead
you're hanging on there but i don't know
how to get you okay
right well i see you over here
oh god
oh no oh god oh god
i'm just punching you in cigarettes
what's going on there
oh god this is the worst okay this this
is how i don't want to die you're being
punched
unconsciousness fell under water oh god
yes climber over here just climbing
everything to victory i wanted to see
i want to see if i could climb it it
turns out you can and it'll tip over
though so
oh no this is it
oh is it this the decider i don't think
so okay now this is
i don't want to die trapped in an
elevator elevator
yeah with this is the big oh my god
oh no this this is a fully a raw shark
moment you know
you're trapped in here with me
oh no
i think i think uh i think john might be
onto something here yeah
he's done the smart thing i think he did
it by accident by falling off and then
yes more i don't have to explain my
little place to you
okay fair enough fair enough you can
make it back in there
oh no what do you think you're doing
i'm in a nap
the other elevator would collapse with
you in it but i mean
this is fine too okay all right i'm in
come in hello oh no
oh wow
[Laughter]
yes
good i feel like alan rickman at the end
of die hard
i was fully like a uh captain america
holding the helicopter and the building
at the same time i have my rippling
muscles yeah
except there's rick sanchez
hello oh
i see you
where you going no god put me down
believe it
[Laughter]
i'm a huge fan of that pun
it's time to take out the trash
hello two more seems like
you've got a train to catch
oh my god are you swinging me around
your head i'm trying to i think it's
gonna kill me first but
you're just holding my hands it's
freaking yeah
it's it's really old never let go can't
punch you because you're holding my hand
oh my god wow that was bad
dude how do i even get out of here where
are you
i'm like on the train track i like held
john in front of the train
and he took the train here and then i
got kicked into it
bizarre have any of any of you
here read the read the uh road the
shinkansen
yeah no no no no no no no no no i almost
did
that's great isn't it donna burke who's
the voice of
no she's not she's one she's the voice
of one line of trains um
oh oh god she does the exact same voice
that she does in mel yeah solid 5.
storm approaching harris please that
time we had breakfast
it was delightful oh it was a really
good breakfast i missed it so it was a
really good breakfast here
what are you doing to that vending
machine lucy no
it swallowed my 50p
i'm trying to get it out i made it
oh i did not well okay okay well i guess
that's why
hello
oh we got some more donations uh oni
dino
gave six dollars and sixty six cents oh
hell yeah pride
hail gay satan hail satan's stream el
satan
hail coco uh sam vining gave 10
thank you so much uh i see you had the
same idea
[Music]
an anonymous game oh no he knows how to
climb i don't know how to climb
i believe if i press one more button i
will drop even though
i think you can only climb so much
before it drops yeah you might be able
to get inside that i can try
um hello if you just joined us we are
raising money
uh for ablegamers.com for 2021.
um they do incredible work to help
gamers with disabilities
working as accessibility consultants and
getting specialized hardware
and putting on events to combat uh
social isolation they're an incredible
charity please check them out uh and
also if you've got a few dollars
or pounds or any uh currency to spare
wow harris won that please i don't know
well you won that
was i thought we won that wow
have i won the right to not be rick
yeah i wanna how do i
how do i change my there isn't the
ferret but that's
oh dear accidentally steam overlay
[Music]
can someone change how do you change
teams
right now looks like it's three versus
one
yeah hang on uh i just did it
accidentally oh here we go
so i'm i'm yellow how do i change skins
we should do gamespot v gamers
the gamers rise up okay
uh you're pressing i really like yours i
think i think you're blue hold on let me
there we go yeah okay okay so um how do
you change
skin i'll be a different animal i would
like to be
something other than a chicken uh press
left or right on d-pad after you've
unreadied
uh so b
oh i'm still on the keyboard oh here we
go
um i
would like to be oh i'm going to be a
lucha libre
are we going with beams right now or is
this yeah let's do teams
and then how do you swap teams uh oh
gang that one there we go
there we go i am a newcastle
yes are you from newcastle originally
i am yeah you can't you can't tell
but now well now you can because you've
mentioned what why whoa
why is it finding other players
it said that before and i think we were
okay yeah
just throwing some randoms coming in
my dad's from newcastle i'm not yeah
where in newcastle if you know uh
careful don't dox yourself
i don't remember um i forget where he
was from originally somewhere in
thailand where
yeah oh man i'm gonna go back up there
hopefully next month sweet very excited
for i'm excited for pint
can you pay attention please it doesn't
cost me the word the world what
this is you know what you just
immediately jumped off
i'm jumping into the fight time no you
gotta play smart
i'm gonna say no oh
[Music]
we have to win this we have to show
people that it's totally fine to give
normal useless people without any
education or training massive followings
that there'll be no reaper questions at
all
yeah if we lose it might seem like we
should have
they should have put their faith in
someone with skills
yeah yeah if we lose goku didn't
goku's training was for nothing yes
i tried to swing thinking there's actual
physics in this game i remember
in order to stop me being into video
games and cartoons
uh my family forced me to learn uh
to play golf oh my god oh what like real
life golf
yeah actual golf and uh i remember the
first thing that happened
was i met a girl who was really into
dragon ball z so
that's awesome
no oh okay well down i go
yes to the ground uh that's funny
because my dad
in an attempt to get me into computer
games uh made me play
golf windows golf oh yes
[Music]
my dad sitting me down when i was a
teenager and being like
you have to stop watching pokemon like
it's getting really weird
and i think suffice to say i showed him
[Laughter]
two weeks later look at you look at me
now
yeah my parents my parents were like you
need to you need to get a proper
education
and i believed it and i did what they
asked and i got a degree in law
and then right at the last second i
pivoted into video games and it was
devastating for them
they were just like god damn you were so
close to being a lawyer and i was
delighted
was i was i ever close or was i just
letting you believe
oh okay tim need help need a help
one i require one help no
hold on hold on hold on i'm just on the
architecture uh yeah i'm just
running where harris is there we go
there he is there he is there he is he's
there
um i remember i'm doing it don't do it
don't do it down
we don't have to we don't have to fight
game is unite
it'll be all right oh i remember my mum
coming in
to my room once and i was playing mass
effect and she was very very dismissive
of her
of it until i told her that i was
basically playing as
james t kirk from star trek and once she
understood that reference
and the fact that i was about to bone a
yeah she was like okay i get it
take a seat well well well
what do we have here oh
help me to a watery graveyard oh my god
what the [ __ ]
is going on what the hell was that
master of two worlds how do you say i'm
on tomorrow's team
and this is now two for two that i have
been abandoned by tam in my
hour of need hey i was helping hey
get off i don't know how you commanded
the kraken to bring you back before but
it won't happen again
this is rey mysterio season you're
coming with me
in the words of scarface the world is
yours for the nintendo wii
what's yours but which i mean mine
yes punch him
into submission yes
oh my god
no the bench is not my enemy anymore oh
wow that was a headbutt and a half
yeah that's the only what move i'd ever
do effectively
oh my god
oh god he's holding my hand
he's using the ultimate martial art
human friendship
i'll never let go of you i'll be here
for you always
no friends for life
it's kraken time yeah you are
you belong to the kraken now
you belong to the kraken now you can
never tame the kraken
thanks tim i take back what i've said
about you abandoned
it was for the greatest there was a
bigger plan happening
i don't think you have to do something
otherwise youtubers are going to look
like idiots
you need to get that guy who suddenly
started doing uh murder
investigation interrogation
documentaries
oh yeah he's blown up on oh yeah he's
huge
oh yeah he like he like saw the
algorithm door was cracked open and just
like snuck in somehow
oh no because i also think and this is
coming
right yeah i mean his videos are great
so
yeah all good but like there was a
definite down
to downtick i think in true crime last
year because everyone was depressed
enough
yeah but then like justin
yeah yeah then the things opening up
again he
he took his shot crime is back on the
menu boys
when you weren't looking crime made a
return do any of you have that thing
where
listening to a true true crime podcast
will make you go asleep
yes i listened to a lot of true crime
podcasts before bed
oh yeah um cause my friends think i'm
insane for that but i'm like no good
good case file right it's case file mine
is case file as well
it's that that voice it's the accent
he did one recently about the watcher
and that actually scared the [ __ ] out of
me
yeah not asleep for that one um the
problem with it is every now and then
he'll do like his soothing voice
talking about crime and then launch into
a an advert for a mobile game called
best fiends
and it's like seven octaves too loud
it's like
and that is when he found out that he
was in the room as a killer
do you like video games on the mobile
phone because
best fiends is great and you're like
holy [ __ ] i was falling asleep man
i'm uh i figured out the ultimate tactic
oh [ __ ] leave me alone
and taken out by the sausages
that was brutal i believe in you lucy
just hang on i'm just hanging on
believe in friendship and hold on to
your friend there's only one arsene
wenger
i don't know who the manager is of
newcastle i have no i mean i have no
idea
the last thing i found out what is it
i have no idea he's a newcastle player
isn't he that would be pretty cool if he
was 20 years ago tom
he is one
yeah yeah analysis desk that's a
esports thing is that the same thing you
pronounce the ocho
they should they should do physical
esports they sound really like you know
great i think they catch on oh
no physical esports
remember folks you can donate at
tinyurl.com for slash play for all 2021
we aren't here just doing it purely
because we like to play games with each
other it's also because we want to help
out some
uh gamers with disability and needs to
be able to play games in a more
accessible manner so please donate
generously
and now watch me throw these fools off
of [ __ ]
and now in the words of disturbed let
the bodies hit them
in the floor this gymnastic display
uh
best use of that song is uh jet li is
the one
yeah 100 no no no i couldn't resist
using that song
in my fake martial arts yeah and i knew
they were gonna steal all the copyright
revenue
and they did and i was like that's a
stupid video no one's gonna watch it
anyway dude and then i was like
six million views later i was like [ __ ]
that video is incredible
it was a really fun one to make like it
was very interesting to dive down that
whole yeah
how long on average does it take you to
i mean on average how long does it take
you to make
both of you a video because i know you
both do like a ridiculous amount of
research
um um i think it depends
uh on the video okay okay okay
like uh the last video i did was on a
topic where we had to get lawyers
involved
because the guy it's about just tried to
sue journalists who covered it
multiple times that's incredible we did
it
that was a mlg win from the two of you
yeah
i just stood there and talked about my
life
um it was basically just like a whole
documentary
uh but made by just one person so it
took six months um
but uh a video about video games
obviously
it's slightly less you know maybe a five
i don't know
yeah um what um what john's process is
though i'm really curious
um it like it kind of depends as well
like i think every video
i make i always start out like i'm gonna
do this in three weeks and it's gonna be
a real clean 20 minute video
and then it always turns into like a 40
minute monstrosity
and i kind of hate it by the end but i
published it anyway
you both do typically like one video at
a time or do you have multiple things
cooking
um
i'll i'll do i'll do one video like
no that will be my entire life for that
month or whatever
and i might i'll be like thinking about
all this stuff but yeah what about you
harris
i try to do multiple but it ends up
being just one
yeah i like having something else i can
do at the same time because then um
if i'm bored i can do something else to
like you know
use my time effectively um
usually every video becomes two videos
at some point and then the other one
doesn't get finished
yeah i think sometimes i have to tell
myself that i'm going to make two videos
out of it just so i have like the balls
to cut stuff
yeah yeah but actually secretly you just
made one good video
with all the stuff that wasn't as
necessary out
yep one big good video yeah
so the the 25 minutes on the cutting
room floor about
uh the quest to find a videotape from
1998
uh can will maybe be a good video later
but it doesn't have to
be i don't know oh my god
i am my producer once
um cat
once made fun of me because she heard me
say
i'm hoping to make this video a short
and sweet 90 minutes
harris has gone too good i have yet to
break the hour mark with a video
it kind of terrifies me
oh yeah i like slam dunked you off that
yeah that was quick i feel dismantled
i feel like a wharf in tng oh i just
bodied instantly
hello uh don't lucy don't fall through
those
well can you there you go there you go
that's why i'm not coming anywhere near
it
it's messed up
um oh my god don't try that [ __ ] with me
i don't think time have you ever made a
video that's an
hour long i think we have i mean we've
done series we've done series
but they were like short yeah
i've written features that are like far
too many words long
and reviews that are perhaps a bit long
but nothing that will take like
months and months of of writing and
research
well actually i've done like interview
lead features and
there are like months of work but yeah
it always gets boiled down to like you
know 3 000 words at most
wow what was that i'm holding on for
dear life
oh god i hate admitting this but i think
shorter things often take more work to
like get
get it really elements i do i agree i
like i would
love like people who are able to make
really concise meaningful like
eight-minute videos i think are the most
talented people in the world
yeah yeah oh yes get off
oh let's see i'm going
down with the ship stay back okay oh
wow i have to applaud it i have to
applaud it heroic sacrifice
uh matthew hawking in chat just said
lucy literally used to have a series
called in two minutes
yeah sure i did nice i used to i used to
be good at just like
very very short videos proto vine
and then youtube came along i was like
no
the algorithm i really hate that because
like that wiped out short animations on
youtube yeah exactly
yeah oh my god jesus
john
enjoy beef
ah beef i'm not leaving without my wife
oh wow no oh that was brew
that was pretty good
i was going to say we got like 35-ish
minutes what should we do for like
donation incentives with this
what i have um i have a 2 liters of
smoke machine fluid by my desk
100 donation and it comes on yeah i
don't know
if it works don't know the nutritional
benefits of it
it's a cell phone
oh my god
this is brutal this is brutal but
it just well i mean we are almost tied
so tim i just think this is this is us
just like letting them get a couple
yeah yeah yeah and then we'll all right
let's go yeah goodbye
i'm pretty sure that's the those are the
important themes
of dragon ball z like friendship is
important
do your best it's safe to drink smoke
machine fluids
and winner gang beasts
always let your moral enemy have two or
three extra chances
yeah oh no oh god announce a tournament
instead of just destroying the world
yeah oh my god
bro what are you doing
well this is interesting
oh no yeah
yes okay okay we're doing it
oh oh no they've broken a head can't
believe it the youtubers are defeating
the gamers
prepared to make a video essay about
this
an analytical deconstruction of how
youtubers defeated gamers
no illegal strat oh oh no i slipped
i'm sorry i slipped as well okay i'm in
i'm back i'm back wait don't try and
jump from point to point it's not worth
it
goodbye no no no
you did what oh it's so hard to get out
yeah
you're charging in
this is this is this is a lot like a
what a beyblade fight looks like to me
i recently figured out that beyblade is
real oh yeah it's
did you not know this i i'm obsessed
i started following a beyblade tick
tucker
wait was it blast zone kid no it's not
no just not blossom kid blossom kid
doesn't have any skill
he's a he's a fraud okay
wow um but yeah it's this guy who like
builds beyblades professionally and i
thought that was like a pretend thing no
dude
i there was a series last last time we
did this
charity thing or it was extra life i
built a beyblade that was
unstoppable it was unreal
so in the in the office we have um the
area called the speed zone where we
watch
speed runs um and also play games
uh but we would kind of hang out there
like speed zone
and we would just watch youtube videos
and somehow i don't know how it happened
but we got onto like beyblade
youtube yeah and there was this kid that
we started following
blaster's own kid and
he sold out because we he did sell out
he plays fortnite now
but we followed his um he went through a
tournament i think that's why we watched
it like there was a whole tournament arc
yeah uh multiple episodes
and yeah this is something that grown
adults did
yeah we watched it and it was initially
it was really endearing because like his
parents used to take him to the
tournament and help him buy beyblades
and he'd like put loads of love and
attention into it
and then he got a lot of attention for
it and he immediately
immediately cashed in like almost
instantly
and it was like uh he's and then he
started doing skits that were like weird
you remember the era or not the era it
still happens
the weird skits where like you dress up
as characters that are licensed and
start doing like vaguely suggestive
stuff
oh yeah he started doing that with
beyblades and stuff and i was like
this is a bit weird it was a joker one
i remember yeah to tie in with the
release of
when he was joking yeah when he was just
like this kid who was doing normal
beyblade stuff like i like logged into
the gamespot youtube channel and would
like
come into his streams and be like hey
man you're cool just to give him like a
little
little like nice nice little boost and
he'll be like oh thanks and stuff like
that
and then he sold out and i was like i'm
blocking him
we're never talking to this loser again
joke's on us he probably has more money
yeah he's probably rich as hell
come here oh no wow he's now a majority
shareholder
and beyblade
but no wow did you just
powerbomb me
stop behaving like a dinosaur open
sorry i can fix that pretty easily
it wasn't my camera again was it yeah it
was yeah
i don't know see if i can fix it i'm
sorry nice all right sorry it happens
this is actually good training for me
oh my god my tail is
stuck that should be back now sorry
about that i have no idea what's
good oh no
leave me alone oh it's perfectly fine i
just dropped you right back in
oh perfect please
and somehow i'm still alive yeah we were
we're being sportsmen like what are you
doing over there lucy
um you might remember the spider-man
movie
one of you one of you have to do an
upside upside down kiss
someone's gotta be a curse and dance in
this scenario
i'm trying to destroy the awning so that
it'll just fall
i have such a strong memory of seeing
that trailer on like an old playstation
2 demo disc
yeah oh man i missed demo discs
yeah i missed demo desk um a demo desk
for
i think it was lord of the rings but it
was an aol demo desk and it was
like the third movie um
had this really weird remix of the song
oh [ __ ]
um the song from what is that
what was that movie with um requiem
requiem for a dream oh yeah but it had
like a weird remix that they put on
the return of the king and it was like
this real weird trailer that i thought i
dreamt up for years i thought i faked
this trailer in my head
and then i just randomly found it on
youtube one day wow and that was
like just my inherent my inherent my
endearing memory of uh demo discs
so you go ahead harris there's a video i
saw that i've been curious if i
imagined it or if it really happened
where
it's the it's an animation from sonic
generations where they free
the crocodile from like being turned to
stone
and like the whole animation plays with
the music and right at the end he opens
his mouth
and he says it's been and then it cuts
and yeah like from the song and wow i
don't i feel like i must have imagined
it because i could never find it again
and i i remade it myself to try and make
an example so people knew what i was
talking about
but never found a copy of it so oh it
drives me insane when there's that one
clip you really want to see
um i always remember there's this
reality tv show and it was like
bad boys academy or something like that
oh and
i saw it like really late oh my god
what's going on lucy
yes let me go no okay fine oh no
yes yes no yes
do it oh my god
life is good
we got it wait so bad boy
academy oh yeah and so they did an art
competition
and this big like jacked guy
turns around his easel and there's a
really shitty drawing of a robot
with a heart in it and it's like really
cute and then he starts crying and he's
like you see this robot's like me
because i got this big strong body but i
got this soft heart inside
and then like i think the presenter of
the show was like is there anything you
want to say to the robot
and he just beats the [ __ ] out of the
easel and he's like i hate you
and i've never been able to find it and
it was oh my god brilliant oh my god
that does kind of sound like a fever
dream that
like downloading a bunch of those old
mtv series and going through them one by
one to try and find it
because like the internet is not like
itv
yeah so might have been actually feels
like an itv one because i remember that
show
where are you going how are you doing
get back
it's time for the drop the ultimate job
kick
god damn it get
sacrifice myself we did it
but at what cost i'm all alone in this
world
and on top of a lighthouse with no way
down
um what are you pressing to make the
constant gurgling noises as terrifying
bugling noises oh i don't have sound on
this so i can't i can't hear anything
well the gang piece is making the
gameweek's going hahaha
constantly they're just
oh my god did you just launch yourself
into the
you did no no
[Music]
okay i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it
here we go if i had
if my guy had like dark hair i would
kevin keegan
i'm not that's again very limited
newcastle football and knowledge
bobby bobby
no no you don't no
augusto is still alive god
yes oh yeah i think he is he's not doing
very well though
that was when he came oh that's right
yeah
oh my god i mean i used to live
near raul moat's house
and yes uh i remember that uh like when
all the police like cordoned all that
off
and then we heard about the gascoigne
stuff can you like turn up with a beer
or something
it was i think it was like fosters yeah
some chicken and a fishing rod
it was something very very strange the
essentials
oh look i thought it was back there it's
just my body being churned in that meat
your body keeps going round and round oh
my god it's horrifying
yeah it's disturbing like i
dimly remembered paul gascoigne dying
and then my first notification that he
was still alive was when he made it you
know when that happened yeah
what oh what's going on here this is
this is a lot this is
you're basically flying at this point
you're both just flying at this point
this is an incredible display
no this is i feel like this is some
legend of ricky oh [ __ ]
yeah this really is let go of the
machine
grab the machine grab the machine again
put your hand in
this machine destroys everything have
you ever
how are you no
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna call that a win
um i remember my mom's my mum's friend
so like have you ever seen a like a
garbage disposal or something and just
kind of like the thought in your head
that just goes what if i stuck my hand
in there
yeah yeah am gone um
just have no concept of
self-preservation but um my mom was
saying that she was on holiday and
like she went in this hot air balloon i
don't know let's go i'm sorry
um and she was saying that like one of
her friends
literally was not allowed in the hot air
balloon because his uh
his impulse to do that kind of stuff is
too strong oh no
yeah just like he wasn't allowed in it's
like it's insurance or something
wow that's crazy
so i don't know why that meat grinder
reminded me of that story but
uh so have you seen
the draw oh my god
we've got a few donations one of them
has a uh a note to john so
uh foxcade is given ten bucks thank you
yeah hi
uh he said hey everyone just wanted to
donate to help a good cause but also to
say john anyway you could fix your
donation link that nightbot keeps
dropping
uh he's already talked about that and
they are lost without you so yeah
eventually yeah yeah there's a
situation on my pc now where i can't
quit out of anything
so the only thing i'd say is do not
donate to the link appearing on my
twitch chat
just go to tinyurl.com forward slash
uh play for all 20 21
or go to my twitter and just donate in
the link there
thank you so much basically whenever i
do anything it just connects the camera
and messes everything up
so i kind of have to just be here yeah
oh
yeah like if i unplug or replug in my
microphone
for some reason um it just disconnects
my camera too so
i was like okay to be fair if you are
donating using that um twitch spot link
it's going to a good place
so yeah i was gonna say all donations to
charity go to great places
also going to a good place and i will
read those donations out friday
but um yeah i also just want to do
ablegamers
for the moment yeah uh so you know in in
like a butcher shops they have the
machine that you make mince meat with
like you like cram the beef into the
hole and it like
minces it up um so like to do that
sometimes you really have to like
poke it in there and like really get in
there so
let me pull you up brother come on one
of my uh
one of my uh okay a person that i know
um was like accidentally got their
fingers caught in that
no oh no yeah so now
oh wow oh yes oh he did it
yeah he he's missing his um he's missing
his
uh middle three fingers his middle
finger
god yeah have any of you seen an
ordinary sausage
no no it's a great youtube channel where
a guy just makes sausages out of things
highly recommended
that's become like a lot of my favorite
kind of online media
yeah there's a girl i follow on tick
tock at the moment and she just
she just really likes making coffee
that's it oh yeah that's
everything about her channel there's one
short short
brown hair i think so yeah yeah there's
one on instagram called coffee bae which
i really like
oh she's the same she just makes loads
of cool coffee
she teaches me how to make really good
coffee and i ignore her her advice
constantly and just get it from the shop
downstairs but i still like it
but one day one day you will make that
yeah you're good
let's not let's not let's not kid
ourselves here this that's
never gonna happen you are accumulating
the knowledge so you have the potential
to make a good coffee
raising my fists and head banging
i am ringing i do not have fallen off
yeah i just kept sliding off five
lie on the times um look like you're
having a good time there
no let me help you let me spread the
word
the good word of crime
oh my god
thank you to captain kirk for 6.99 thank
you captain
oh my god this is bruce this is brutal
sand noodle uh ten dollars uh and they
ask
john and harris say hail satan
hell satan uh i've spent a lot of
satanic activity on my end recently
which
might explain all the satan i mean we're
last podcast on the left fans and they
sign off all of their podcasts with hail
satan so
yes uh teresa river
revolve uh 20 thank you for doing the
good work
thank you for doing the donation um
and efren flores 50 donation
thank you hell yeah nice thank you so
much efren
every penny counts folks please donate
if you can generously if you can't
share the link around you might like
someone who can donate might see it
and think huh i'm up for that
why do we look like yeah why do we look
like a mischievous
duo here like the chuckle brothers
he's trying to get away get him
i walk into a trap in the door
i fear we're walking into a trap
i've got one oh
here's the thing about tam right he's
too much of a coward to fight me on the
conveyor belt
you know that's not gonna work on me
it's absolutely gonna work i'll be there
in a second
let's go boy let's do this all right
what'd you say about no me was my tactic
all along i'm gonna take you out and
leave them fight it one-on-one never
care if you kill both yes
i fell into the trap i'm gonna snap your
[ __ ] neck
this just looks like a really nice like
synchronized dance between two
partners oh the reversal what
it's like ice skating ballet that's one
thing that my tick tock has given me a
lot of recently and that is uh olympics
a lot oh my god and i did get some of
the olympics um
swimming the other day which looked very
difficult harrison's got the
i just got the best celebrations post
game
he's got the hands over the head he's
got the fist punch i finally like last
week started playing fortnite and
it's just yeah it's uh i'm
i finally i'm learning how to dance
enjoy our generation was meant to oh
yeah
i still have never played it just
because i haven't played it it's fun
yeah it's fun i i got into it for a
while because my
roommate was playing wouldn't it be
really depressing if it turned out to be
the worst game ever
yeah and we were just like after after
everything
you know no oh
don't grab my cape okay i'll try and re
i'll try and
lean you over yeah get him
damn don't let them swing over to you
i don't know how long i can hold on for
oh
yeah reach up reach up no no
oh man oh my god
uh paul in the chat says magustilations
deletions to you
megustylations i was gonna say hard game
but
i probably shouldn't shout that no no it
should be
no one should be sh hiling edging that
loudly
wow lucy straight in the drink is it i
straight in there
looked at the chat for one second wow
you can't you can't look away you can't
look at me let your guard down
around these youtubers this is how they
works
distracting the youtubers they're sneaky
you look away for a second next thing
you know you subscribed you're watching
a 30 minute video
that's how it works
i think we just simultaneously knocked
each other out lucy
you let go of my friend
i've watched cyber shells entire hour
long video about what chao
are twice in the last two days oh my god
it's so cyber feels great relaxing he's
so good yep
oh i can't believe you finally came back
throughout these years yeah um
you're joshua stevenson it's incredible
yeah joshua stephenson in chat says
this is the level with the most bugs
right now why is that is that because of
the the kraken
i guess it's got a lot of skinny it's
been it's been out for almost 50 years
i mean i haven't encountered a single
bug yet it seems flawless
[Music]
the guy with the host advantage hasn't
noticed any problems no great that's a
that's actually a good
mix do you think good line of thing and
not like line of questioning but like
we're talking about uh
youtubers you're like who are your
favorite youtubers
i mean you mentioned a bunch there but
i'm not um i'm genuinely not doing a bit
when i say super live patchwork is one
of my favorite youtubers but um
oh i mean same hair same here
i would be remiss not to shout out um
mecca gamezilla
or also known as the infinite review
yeah it's the best
ah don't
just stay in there
oh wait apparently this is a new level
so that's why this one has oh wow
i like that they're still adding stuff
to it yeah thoughtful um
out of a few like it's it's gonna be so
corny i hate saying but genuinely
you know h-bomb for a very very long
time has been
like one of my absolute top core high
heels is great
yes so is nero um there's actually a
youtuber followed relatively recently
hazel um and she did an amazing video
called um why we liked elfin lead
oh it's if you remember elf and lead it
was that anime that people would be like
have you ever seen and it's really edgy
and kind of terrible and she just did
this incredible
two-hour deep dive on it and
that was just just so so good
um thank you so much i want to say thank
you for you you shouted me out
in like 2017 and it was the coolest
thing in the world
oh no problem thank you so much
oh my god that's that's one thing i like
to do with my channel uh
shout out infinitely better youtubers
oh well i need to check out the selfie
video now oh yeah i'll be actually i'll
be actually shouting her out in a
upcoming favorite things video
that is incredible those i love those
videos so much they're my favorite
things
they're so good they're so fun to make
and they're so much
easier than anything else i make
yeah and i can also shoehorn wrestling
in there which makes me happy
you know what else is easy victory
donating to ablegamers all you gotta do
is go to tinyurl.com
play for all 2021 and that is as harry
says the true victory in life
ablegamers uh doing a lot of great work
for
um gamers with disability
so please if you can donate trying to
raise 30k
shooting for the moon here um we want to
try and get that uh
that'll be an incredible amount to
commit to the
charity yeah stephen
uh is doing a he's trying to raise a
million
by the end of the by the end of the year
but there's not that much to go so we're
trying to
contribute as much as you can yeah it's
like a community goal that he's put
together it's like a
everyone can become a kind of like a
supporter of his
effort and all the money raised
collectively gets put towards the
overall goal
um and we're just trying to help them
make a decent dent towards getting to
one million
that's great it's lovely i like the the
system you've got
where you do a couple of things a day it
seems really
really good yeah saves on burning out
and stuff
yeah we did uh daily streams for like
six weeks last year
oh gosh which was it was a lot like
it was a lot but it was awesome yeah
like i like
it it felt weird at the time because it
felt like oh e3
and then we'll do this for a little bit
but just because we got the kind of to
keep going it kind of
i don't know just spread out the i don't
know the kind of
the joy of it because like this isn't
something that we typically do in our
day-to-day
job like you know tam managing editor
i'm a
senior video producer like we just do
like a lot of admin
as well as writing stuff and so it's
nice to let loose and actually
play more games and like i said before
we went live like with with
folks that we uh most of the teams but
like folks that we admire like other
people in the industry who we
wouldn't necessarily get to interact
with much and just friends as well
yeah saying that we're just taking over
game spot like one stream at a time then
you'd be crying
absolutely correct please do
it's the great british invasion of the
site
this is how we do it well i mean you say
that my accent when i'm over there yeah
i mean
your accent has traveled more than i
have in my life
yeah i think it's like it's a really
cool thing that you guys have done
as well and like even for me like
getting the email from utam last year
just been like hey do you want to do a
thing for
gamespot was like really cause like
i can remember like sifting through n64
no mercy screenshots on game spot
yeah the idea of being on it was was
bizarre but it was so cool
actually yeah that's the wildest thing
like for me it was like i i have that
exact same memory
of like looking through the the low-res
screenshots on gamespot.com
um so i very much yeah i mean they're
all mostly there yeah so like i have
i share that same kind of like sense of
awe when i and the thing about working
here now is
it's the the best thing about it is it's
got enough clout that i can approach
people that i love
and the work of like you guys and be
like hey gamespot will you work with us
and honestly it's selfish it's selfish
like i just wanted to be on a stream
with
you know you guys because i love your
work and i know that it's gonna
it's gonna be not only will i have a
good time but it will contribute to a
good cause so
i'm just using the gamespot name for my
own benefits
and for the sake of cherry yeah
um ah get up there we go okay
um just gonna watch and see what happens
here
uh like one of the things that like
doing this
last year i think we we set up a game
swatch
over a year ago now and that was like
john luke and jake really wanted
to have a place that wasn't just like a
comment section and
this community has grown in that time
and it's just like
we don't have moderators and we've never
needed to moderate anything because
everyone in there is just so nice
yeah we've got like a couple of staff a
couple of users
that keep an eye on things but
everyone's just so wholesome in there
never had a bad problem anything like
that that's pretty cool
it's real nice there's like a really
nice little uh
i mean it's like most discord
communities there's like a really nice
little fitness community in there where
you go in there and everyone's just
being like
supportive to each other being like yeah
you can do it today man
go for it my favorite is the uh
photo mode yeah
leaves me alone oh my god i could
you know like you've got that you've got
a hangover you're just pressing your
face to the cold concrete floor
um so youtube chat someone uh say
bootsu uh asks are there any any super
small youtuber recommendations say under
a thousand subs
that you guys like slash think need some
eyes
oh gosh that's a hard one really hard to
find people who are under a thousand
subs yeah
um there's a there's this channel that
recently came onto my radar that's
pretty good like they're pretty new and
i think they're gonna get like a lot
better as
time goes on but lines in motion i think
they're called i can't remember how much
they have but it's not that many
there's one uh there's a music like i
really like music youtubers
just like play stuff i found her in tik
tuk she's not 1k
she's like 60 or something like that her
name is stacy ryan
and she just does like uh jazzy covers
of other songs i found her on tik tok
and
such a good youtube uh account uh
channel to check out just nice follow
him alex mccallum music
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah alex mcallister
he's amazing
have we not had him on something i think
we've like worked with him in the past
maybe wait is he bloodborne is funky
no no no yes oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah we put him in the uh
no you're hmong he's you see his toast
um yeah
video speed run video yeah what are we
doing here it's just like a nice little
dance
[Music]
oh my god i was dancing and you were
trying now
i was doing i was just practicing oh we
got a bunch more donations i'm going to
read them out uh
liam grenland uh gave ten dollars looks
like you've got a
crane to catch up oh
keep rocking on and appreciate all the
hard work we're going out together we're
going out together
but you're going to get you're going to
take the brunt of the damage from me
no here we go
is neo
what that train clearly hit two people
uh we got five dollars from dj mizzy
thank you so much
uh i don't know how to read
gabriel's there's a lot of asterisks in
it
but i'll try my best five dollars for
gabriel thank you
take my blank christian blank euros
and troll those false prophets to blank
oh that's
beefed up soul that's for a super high
patchwolf thing that he's doing
uh might be yeah sorry again to everyone
for the confusion with the donation
links there i will read those donation
links but
yeah that is uh also that stream
also that whole idea is incredible yeah
i love it yeah i love it
it was hopefully i don't get sued let's
see
i mean yeah always countless who
i mean surely they'll just forgive you
right i mean they are christians
what's going on here how are you flying
get off me
believe believe
all right lucy who'd be some of your
favorite youtubers
oh i mean obviously you like genuinely
drinking
i know you stopped power drive power
drive
oh this is incredible yeah
yeah i will drown you
uh contra points lindsay ellis i love
um andrew jrt does amazing
overwatch stuff uh jacob gallagher
what oh he's great yeah yeah yeah
he did a really good simpsons one
recently yeah yeah yeah
he did one um it was about like music
and horror games that was really really
good
oh that's so good and i think music's so
hard to talk about and he did such a
good job
yeah all right we've come to the end of
our stream
sadly um it's hard to tell who was the
victor but i'm pretty sure it was me
um i'm going to claim a kind of moral
victory if i can
that's fine you can as long as it's not
the main victory i don't care what kind
of
you think it's not it's moral victory
but thank you so much harris and john uh
for hanging out with us and playing um
for gang beasts and not heepo uh
but for everyone watching please
continue to donate and we're going to be
back tomorrow
um we're going to what are we doing
tomorrow i can't even remember
uh so we've got john robertson's dark
room at
uh 10 am pt 6 pm uh uk
which is if you've never seen the dark
room before john is
a comedian and it is an interactive
live-action uh role-playing game or like
a dungeon no it's a dungeon
uh it's an adventure game uh you awaken
in a dark room and you have to find
your way out and john is essentially
like a dungeon master who
is incredible it's very very funny so
that's at 10 a.m
and then at 12 p.m uh is it 12 p.m
no 2 p.m pt 10 p.m
gmt we have our friend some kind of
funny
uh we've got greg blessing and
mike snow bicycle micical and we're
going to be playing
some knockout city which reminds me that
i need to get the kind of funny emblem
inside yeah uh eduardo guy where can
people find you if they want to check
out more of your stuff
um youtube.com h from a guy
wow who would have thought it and super
apache wolf
i mean um you can just google super
patchwolf and i'll i'll be there
yeah and i i highly recommend doing both
because they are two of the best
creators on youtube
my i love watching this stuff so take it
from me it's highly worth your time
thank you again guys hang on wait wait
um
i have to read the donations man okay
yeah okay
uh so twenty dollars from anonymous the
cosmic fly fifteen dollars thank you so
much
um say seibutsu who asked the question
in chat
um about smaller youtubers gave seven
dollars and said not much be glad to
give what i can
thank you have a fun rest of the stream
and best of luck everyone
socialist audiophile in there again
thank you so much with 89
and one cent and then
anonymous has just dropped a thousand
dollars wow
thank you thank you so much anonymous oh
my goodness
[ __ ] thank you so much anonymous wow a
legend thank you so much
yes the mark of the beast yes
let's go thank you so much to everyone
that has
donated um and once again thank you uh
harrison john
it's been an absolute pleasure i'm so
glad we got to play games together
yeah um this is great yeah we'll have
you back on for stuff soon hopefully if
you're around but all right everyone
take care we'll see you tomorrow